oh ho ho is it that time of year already
the nights are getting longer it's
getting colder and the number of pumpkin
spice latte pictures on Instagram is
reaching critical mass well I hope
you've been good this year Boys and
Girls because father Christmas is
offering a price cut on the Xbox one
this holiday season so if you're in the
market for an xbox one you may want to
wait until this weekend to give in and
buy one microsoft announced today that
it is cutting the consoles price by
fifty dollars effective from the second
of november by the last this offer is
valid in the united states only for now
the rest of the world clearly got stuck
on the naughty list the limited time
promotional offer applies to any Xbox
one console so this means you can get
the kinect free system for three hundred
and fifty dollars or the standard kinect
bundle for four hundred and fifty
dollars the price cut also applies to
special edition bundles including the
likes of Assassin's Creed unity sunset
overdrive and call of duty advanced
warfare which also comes with a one
terabyte hard drives the promotion is
valid until the third of January 2015
and will be available across the United
States at most major retailers including
amazon best buy gamestop microsoft
stores target toys r us and walmart well
Americans fifty dollars off is
definitely better than a lump of coal in
your stocking for all the latest on the
Xbox one make sure you keep your eye on
gamespot